all right Mark Wahlberg loved the
left-handed golfer a good setup I've
played with mark he can play I played
with Phil he didn't give me a single bit
of advice doesn't look bad guts speed he
hits it hard so your first move back
when your head slides back it's killing
you that's what's making it hard to
return to square and you're having a
hard time finding it yes getting through
the ball this way keep that left the
pressure on your left foot on the inside
part of your foot so that you don't sway
back with your head and that will make
returning the club to square much but
he's using a 10 year old square driver
come on man hey let me call Callaway
room but he's had a little downtime or
the movies are struggling upgraded 12
years can we send him a rogue so that he
can fix his [ __ ] up
you got the rope thank you I will try it
and then I'll probably end up giving it
to somebody there's just something about
the feel of the square head the Old
Faithful I just play with Tiger our play
Pebble Beach like you can't pull that
Club out I'm like dude if I hit it long
and I hit it straight I'm playing with
it I dude I had Phil's driver I think
almost broke it because so stiff he's
playing at the Madison Club Phil won
everything
Phil wins everything yeah I kind of give
you that what do we just talk trash on
the floor like my kids at Christmas
expect me to clean it all up
who I like the shaft look looks good I
need a little thicker grip Thank You
Phil good luck against Tiger man he's on
fire I know
instant family comes out November 16th
if this is the movie of the year that
will make you laugh and make you cry and
probably make you want to go out and
extend your family